los hombres asiáticos estadounidenses
tienen el mayor ingreso como sabes 10 a
10 heridos de los hombres blancos es que
no lo sé
reunimos a siete trabajadores con
salario mínimo gano salario mínimo yo
gano salario mínimo yo gana salario
mínimo yo gano salario mínimo gano
salario mínimo yo gano salario mínimo
gano salario mínimo alguien está
mintiendo si el grupo descubre quienes
compartirán un premio en efectivo
si el mentiroso kahn a él o ella se
llevará el premio
[Música]
vivo en el condado de orange la renta es
difícil es difícil pero estoy recién que
ciudad
en el lado malo él estaba dudando mucho
y parecía que estaba mintiendo yo vivo
con mis padres no pago renta y vivo en
el centro mi prioridad cuando me pagan
es el poke y la renta está ok dáttilo
tengo 24 y 3 y en redes con tus padres
sí porque debo 20 mil dólares es una
oportunidad para intentarlo es difícil
conduzco un über y tengo una camioneta
la compré porque pensé que ganaría más
dinero pero gastó demasiado en
combustible así que debe comprar un
prius esfuerzas para hacernos creer que
estás en la quiebra no solo estoy en la
quiebra solo debo 20 mil dólares lo
mismo en qué trabajas yo soy consultor
de arte consultor de artes y de obras de
arte en varios hoteles eso da mucho
dinero
los artistas y los consultores no son
para nada ricos a menos que sean de los
pioneros cuando dirías que ganas al mes
en comisiones yo sólo he vendido dos
obras en cuatro años cuando ganaste por
eso la obra que vendí costaba unos dos
mil dólares sólo has vendido dos obras
en cuánto tiempo cuatro años si es muy
difícil
es difícil que alguien joven desarrolló
una lista de clientes para llamar y todo
eso pueden hacerlo desearía que mis
padres pudieran comprar a obras como
esas pero si me baso en lo demográfico
que es algo de lo que sé yo
sé que los hombres asiáticos
estadounidenses tienen el mayor ingreso
promedio y
es que no lo sé
pero sólo me baso en lo que sé es
difícil es difícil aunque las
estadísticas que esas digan eso en
realidad no aplica para una minoría como
nosotros rasurar tus piernas no lo haces
cuando vi sus pantalones de basketball y
sus piernas sin rasurar supe que era una
señal basuras tus piernas no de acuerdo
esa es una señal una señal
[Risas]
[Música]
parecía sospechosas y que fuera
eso me entristece creemos que eres
millonario gracias
me sorprende que los demás no votarán
por kevin davies en la primera ronda me
veo pobre dios
gibral esto creo que todos pensaban
estos de niños que harían si fueran
millonarios que es lo primero que harían
para ser sincera invertir en un negocio
para tener más dinero ahora mismo tengo
un negocio en línea pero comencé apenas
hace dos meses y cómo va diría que va
bien empecé apenas hace dos meses y soy
estudiante de verdad espero que crezca
así cuando termine la universidad podría
empezar mi negocio ser me provee ifa es
una tienda en línea creo que es un poco
sospechosa porque parece ser una mujer
muy inteligente y capaz de ser
millonaria no lo dudaría estás
estudiando por internet tomo clases en
línea de contabilidad donde viven tus
madres viven en un in oregon no diré que
vivías con ellos bueno vivían ahí y
luego se mudaron a los ago
y dijo que vivía aquí con sus padres y
luego dijo a mis padres viven en eugene
que queda en oregón sólo pensé arruinó
su historia preguntaste de dónde eran
los padres no pregunté dónde vivían
viven en los ángeles lado oeste oeste no
un apartamento con tus padres así es sí
a juzgar por vivir con mis padres por
algún motivo creo que él y ella son los
más sinceros no sé si es por sus
sonrisas pero creo que
suele pasar con los ricos y divinos
parece rico
[Música]
ah
adiós lo siento muy bien cuando votaron
por mí me sentí mal es extraño que
quieran sacar té me sentí como en esas
competencias en las que apagan tu
antorcha y es el fin no lo sé no estuvo
bien
levanten la mano si tienen alguna duda
es una influencia
ahora que quiere tener una tienda debe
ser influencia creo que en este juego
dejarse llevar por las apariencias no
nos llevará a ninguna parte de verdad
señores mi estrategia si así quieres
juzgar a los demás bien por ti creo que
la ropa no importa la apariencia tampoco
quién está mintiendo sospechaba mucho de
kevin tú eres el otro sospechoso porque
eres
creo que debe ser una chica por eso
levante la mano no será quien yo creía
así que debe ser una de las chicas odio
decirlo pero así es este mundo nunca
sospechamos de las mujeres pero yo no
pienso igual es decir mi madre siempre
ha sido una líder desde que yo era un
niño así que sigue entiendo lo que dice
eso sí si nos quedan 36 segundos chicos
nunca trabajo para trabajo en
construcciones durante 30 años solo
trabaja tu padre si tuviste una infancia
muy buena así
pensé que debía votar por él solo para
sacarlo del camino porque comenzaba a
parecerme realmente muy sospechosa
[Música]
los vería fuera
es decir sabía que me iría pude haber
escrito cualquier cosa en esa tarjeta y
nada había cambiado esta vez haremos una
ronda rápida tienen un minuto que
empieza ahora
[Música]
tienes tu propio negocio en línea si
apenas comencé a finales de julio
desearía no haber hablado de mi negocio
apenas lo empecé hace dos meses es muy
nuevo no soy millonaria solo por eso
cuando llegue a blandos gano bien de
acuerdo hasta ahora he ganado muy poco
quizás sólo unos tienes un canal de
cintos no tengo muchos suscriptores ahí
pero si tienes uno y el último vídeo
hace sin comprimir cuántos seguidores
tienes en instagram quizás son los
número que sea los seguidores en
instagram significan dinero cuántos
seguidores en instagram si unos dos mil
no lo sé unos mil espera cuántos te 1200
y entrevista empresarial es algo nuevo
ampliación de cientos tienes 201 te
seguiré al terminar esto no puede ser
sólo porque dijo que era emprendedora y
tenía que votar por alguien
lo siento
[Música]
lo sabía
envíame el enlace de tu tienda de ropa
bien no lo sé en serio de verdad no creo
que parece que tú ocultas algo pero no
estoy seguro la compañera se viste muy
bien mundialmente no no sospecho de ti
sí al principio no sos el sabadell pero
si hay que eliminar a alguien ahora que
sea y debes ser tú los 100 y una
película el otro día y la cantidad de
hombres que derrochan dinero el hecho de
que cuenten acusarme me hace sospechar
de ambas no creo que sea su turno en que
hagamos tenemos que votar por alguien
intenta hasta acusarme solo debería
soportar eso se pusieron algo agresivas
y cuando alguien se pone agresivo puede
ser porque miente así que pensé a una de
ellas podría estar mintiendo
deberíamos votar 50 y 50 a 300 acaso
tienen seguro médico este mi mamá he
igualmente que obtienen tengo 22
si yo 19 poder femenina ella apoyaba el
poder femenino y yo también
[Música]
era lo mejor es decir si eres millonario
no necesitas el al mero me verdad haría
modelo veces y el millonario gana el
dinero ahora me siento muy confiado y si
la luz se pone verde significa que
expulsaron al impostor y ganan si la luz
se pone en rojo el impostor sigue y
pierden espero que no sean rojas
pero ella no sabía estaba confiada
podría el impostor dar un paso adelante
lo sabía
lo siento chicos tienes una camisa de
cocodrilo me parece algo tonto no lo sé
lo supe por los zapatos y los de oregón
dije última porque en realidad soy de
cuando comencé mi canal de youtube y las
cosas comenzaron a salir bien
todo cambió para mí monetariamente pero
soy el mismo sigo usando estas camisetas
y aún uso estos pantalones sucios a
diario siete días a la semana y también
uso sandalias casi todo el tiempo nada
cambió excepto algunas cifras y mi
cuenta bancaria
en realidad la creí que ganaría no sé
por qué pensé que pasaría algo
celebramos mi
[Risas]
y quiero que todos ganen así que les
daré a todos los perdedores la misma
cantidad que ganaron las chicas para que
todos se vayan de aquí con dinero muy
bien grandioso muchas gracias
gracias a kevin todos somos ganadores
hojitas
de jubilee vive intensamente